see the dollar bill in your back pocket
that's not actually money by the promise
of it from from roll please the Federal
Reserve well let's back up the Fed was
founded in nineteen thirteen to make
sure American banks remain stable emits
any crisis and when there'd be a case of
banking panic the Federal Reserve would
be there to save the day how with loans
the Fed is a hybrid between a public and
private institution calling itself
independent within the government and
loans from the Fed come in the form of
the federal reserve note which is
printed by the Department of the
Treasury so that's that I owe you and
your wallet
you